I think math more about the bias of the
listeners maybe the fact that they've
not really listening to the Outlands of
the past because they're being jasm has
been this stigma around jazz I think one
of the good things about us this year is
that people have been told by the
industry to listen to us so they've been
given you know they've given us a chance
they're given they've given as the
benefit of the doubt
whereas in the past because there's a
stigma of the token Java people don't
only listen to the album's so I think
it's this whole tide is changing because
for so long
yeah it's important to portray a message
because this is the reality that we live
you know we live in a time where we have
to question our leaders or else they
gonna screw us over we have the question
patriarchy or else it's gonna come for
both women and men patriarchy but you
know we've got the one of the highest
levels of male suicide in Britain that's
to deal with patriarchy as well as you
know the glass ceiling for women and in
general the skewing of our view of
history because of a shrink patriarchy
and privilege demonic ease and is
demonic a demonic user system this place
is some other topic and therefore
somewhere bottom so we're here to
question that and to get other people to
just think about the values that they
take as a given we want people to
disrespect and if phrase to our Queens
you know like for me an artist and for
us arts history isn't just about playing
an instrument it's not just about
delivering sonic music it's about
opening the audience's world you know to
the world of someone who has a different
attitude to life and our attitude is one
where we really look to the Past for
inspiration we look to various living
figures for our enlightenment so to be
able to bring that in audience is you
know one of our big missions
my grandmother my great-grandmother 480
cement we lift off under this tree yeah
it's just a comments to the strength and
the perseverance of someone who's
actually been able to be alive on the
earth still with like optimism and a
sense of strength White's at the rate at
the end the the difference now is that
men are starting to listen critically
you know Minnesotans to see their role
within a system that has oppressed women
or treated them in different ways
so in fact nothing every man has a duty
to self-reflect and Sassie see you know
the fact that if the Arbroath are live
in a patriarchal system it's not a
question it's just a fact you know what
are the ways in which our views of
reality eschewed by the system that we
live within this has led us to name in
the tracks after powerful women because
before if we can name easily ten great
men throughout history what about the
women is it that easy to do and then
what we realize it's not actually it
shouldn't be taken as a given